well we're here in the city of odessa in
southern ukraine and this city is widely
thought to be one of vladimir putin's
next targets right on the black sea as a
result people here have been preparing
in a number of ways
and this is one of them you see this
staircase that has just been opened up
here leads down to a series of tunnels
the catacombs below the city actually go
down about four stories very deep and
they were dug back in the 19th century
at the time people
were using the materials from below the
ground to help build houses above during
the second world war these tunnels were
turned into shelters and they are being
repurposed once again with the looming
threat of invasion from russia and now
anytime people in this area hear a siren
warning of a possible russian air strike
they come down into these tunnels
hundreds of them at a time potentially
and as you can see local residents here
have been busy at work they have set up
electricity here
there's even wi-fi
wireless internet setup in these tunnels
other people have brought down food
supplies
water bedding allowing them if needed to
stay down here for a couple of days now
before russia's recent invasion these
catacombs had been effectively closed
people could take a tour of them if they
made a request to the city beforehand
and had a tour guide guide them through
but now they have become reopened
volunteers helping to bring them back to
life and these 200 year old tunnels are
now providing a lifeline for a city
under threat
jeff semple global news odessa ukraine